bonjour à tous je dis cela vous allez
bien et qu'elle était le tueur est
dégueulasse parce que celle et le micro
externe dans la mare mais qu'il a plus
de piles j'ai peur de la cob
regardez-moi ça c'est ballot la vie en
hausse est triste on fait un bilan de la
situation vous dites que jumbo est
quelqu'un de bien
adorable aujourd'hui je suis là pour
établir la vérité sur jumbo sur ce petit
ton cul les dauphins de merde il faut au
moins une énorme connerie par jour qui
me prend une heure à nettoyer tout à
cette vidéo c'est parce qu'il a encore
fait qu'honorer brûle t et vous avez
raison de vous le dire qu'est ce qui a
bien pu faire ce petit con c'est
pourtant très simple regardez là bas nul
est juste là je te baise comme ça à moi
y est on m'explique
ces [ __ ] de traces de crocs dans la
bouteille cette fontaine de l'équipe
hervé parent tout ici
alors il s'est pris une petite spéciale
je peux une petite fessée aura là
j'entends par là bien sûr je ne fera pas
mais [ __ ] qu'est-ce que j'ai engueulé
il d'ailleurs introuvable à ce jour
parce qu'il n'est ni dans mon bureau ni
dans cette pièce ni dans celle là dit
d'or celle là c'est non plus lui ai fait
je vous baise mais où peut-il bien m je
me le demande
serais-tu caché en position foetale
john bost t'as pas honte dit bonjour aux
gens sourient voit la fesci à millions
de caméras tension c'est tout ce que tu
sais faire
hop là on lève la queue bâtard c'est un
exemple tout comme par exemple oui je
sais il reste des pattes parce que je me
suis empressé de faire cette vidéo
tellement j'avais la rage ce petit
placard tourne enfin que 90% des
français possèdent ne se ferme pas il ya
une fente et bizarrement c'est pile la
largeur qu'ils font au coach un
brouillard regarder à des [ __ ] de
poils comme témoin ça montre bien qu'il
y va tout le temps ce petit [ __ ]
résultat je dois mettre que des [ __ ]
de boîtes de conserves parce que ça
c'est dont elle ne passe pas tu l'aies
c'est ici qu'il avait volé les kellogg's
il ya trois jours sa bouffe est posée
ici il est vrai une fois j'ai la flemme
de la mène en placard et la dernière
fois le paquet il a éventré même sans
les vidéos du match à john bost gaming
plus tard dans cubaine je suis gentil je
reçois un colis qu'est ce que je fais
bah je mets les petits papiers partout
par terre comme ça il peut jouer avec
comme ça s'amuser c'est drôle on arbre à
chat qui correspond à une villa pour
arnaud maintenant dans un volet de la
celle de luke avec qui elle de tourner
c'est de réparer la tsr elle bah oui on
va aussi aller solide l'ucad et qui
tourne le dos pour pouvoir y déposer
plainte - partout où tu te reproche
quelque chose non mais tu me dire
regardez le il faut que je nettoie il
s'est mis du lait partout dessus là les
poils tout des dieux bref de quoi les
flux les gens comme lui sur le net
compétition après c'est aussi ça avoir
un animal c'est des petites caresses
comme ça tous les jours c'est les fesses
qui se lève à chaque caresse pour avoir
toujours plus de caresses c'est aussi du
ronron mais certains actes et rendez
vous dire ce chat c'est quoi on va
tendre un guet-apens un peu mou je vais
te filme en cachette un jour ils se
montreront grand public ce sera la suite
de cette vidéo par eto'o tu veux tendre
oublier c'est pas le malin avec moi j'ai
fait un faux pas parce que tu as lu un
mythe de l'est aujourd'hui
aucun de nous regarder nous on se dit
qu'il avait vu ni connu
[Musique]
ça vient tout de suite regardé le
tableau mais oui c'est ça de mots c'est
ça
ils bloquent ici je pense qu'il a
d'avoir mieux en mieux ça explique
pourquoi il ya la gueule écrasé yverdon
cas d'espèce du coup je manque de
respect je me pose chez lui dans sa
maison
olala ce qu'on est bien là dedans john
monde s'est tu voyais comme je suis bien
bon là ça serait mieux d'avoir un chat
je veux dire surtout si c'est pour le
voir dépasser sa tête d'une marche
voilà c'était moi qui m'énerve mon chat
une vidéo qui n'a aucun intérêt aucun
sens en tout cas félicitations vous
venez de regarder le blog le plus cliqué
du monde sa part sur une baisse elle
clairement là ya du travail est passé
ça me regarder d'abord faire vu du temps
de vie que de lourdes
pis
et m